je suis inquiet parce qu'il n'a pas eu
d'emplois
le riz vous présenter aux européennes
vous vous croyez à brosses à cheveux
baba de soutien je m'en tiens on voit
rien on balkans jeu quand on vous dit
que quand on vous dit que vous êtes un
petit peu trop sophistiqué et
effectivement je suis né sophistiqué
mais j'apprends au naturel j'ai dit ah
ouais peut-être j'ai du mal alors mais
c'est normal que vous soyez né
sophistiqués pour pour tout un tas de
raisons d'abord parce que vous êtes la
petite fille de l'ambassadeur à paris
car c'est des soirées de l'ambassadeur
alors ensuite vous appelez sonnerie de
fromental or ici c'est quand même un peu
la haute quoi ariel sonnerie de
fromental âgées c'est génial dommage
d'avoir enlevé parce que sonnerie c'est
joli c'est mieux qu'une cloche c'est
vrai 60 ans dans un corps de cyril dites
vous franchement ensuite vous êtes né au
mexique
quand vous êtes arrivé à paris vous avez
été élevé par des vieilles dames très
chic comme ça et donc voilà c'est pour
ça que d'être comme ça en fait et enfin
des vieilles dames il s'agit surtout de
ma grand-mère où il adore et qui avait
en effet 60 ans de plus que moi et c'est
vrai que j'ai toujours eu une tendresse
infinie pour les gens beaucoup plus
âgées et notamment pour les vieux et le
chance avec les grands mères sont
souvent plus âgés que nous et voilà je
vous la france ce soir découvrez sa
grand-mère lui rend hommage à ma
grand-mère et à toutes les grands mères
de france car les gens âgés sont souvent
les grands oubliés des retraités c'est
vrai
pour moi le ménage donc ariel vous
arrivez du cinéma parce que vous avez vu
plein de films pour votre jules guesde
présidente alors là il faut le dire des
présidents du jury de la 13e édition des
acteurs à l'écran c'est ça voilà les
acteurs à l'écran à saint denis
et alors je me répète mais je veux dire
que tout de même saint denis ce n'est
pas une banlieue c'est la capitale du
monde 4 milliard et demi de gens ont eu
les yeux braqués sur saint denis ça de
nice est une ville formidable et saint
denis c'est une ville culturellement
formidable et bien d'un délit tel que
les gens retiennent à paris la première
chose mais bon c'est la rue samonzet
raison et leur saint denis c'est le
saint des cas pete est bien sûr on peut
le voir aussi d'ailleurs
il est à gauche dans notre dame on voit
la csu callas tête à la main l'a séduit
non ça serait déjà mais sont pas des cas
précis les bouillons sait jamais je ne
me savais qu alors dites moi mais ça à
chaque fois
voit donc alors vous êtes présidente du
jury un voile à travers le film va
penser donc 28 mars ont renvoyé plein de
films x on est obligé voirie mais je
vous assure qu'on les voit avec joie
d'abord parce qu'on n'est pas seul
c'est un festival quand même très très
ouvert puisque pour 100 francs
on peut voir sans fil plus la nuit du
court métrage et c'est vraiment d'une
gaieté c'est une fête c'est le grand
stade qui continue il faut le dire même
si vous habitez marseille mais pour
seulement 100 francs retard et les gens
des cimes à saint denis
ça c'est quand même important il ya deux
prix qui vont être distribués le prix
musidora voilà le prix musique de
récompenses quoi qui récompense les
meilleurs jeunes acteurs de l'année le
prix niel le prix michel simon s'est
donc les longs métrages et ce sont en
effet les acteurs qui viennent d'éclore
parce que c'est simplement premier ou
deuxième film s'est propagée dans cette
émission il y avait deux blondes ce soit
en supplie bon on va m'en passer à
l'interview maintenant vous estimez pas
une vrai que pas du tout dites-moi
arielle dombasle
vous avez une carrière éclectique que
c'est assez de romer à miami vice enfin
en français on dit deux flics à miami
l'an je vous le dis et les américains
avait dit à l'époque de miami vice vous
est l'animal le plus sexy que la france
nous est donné depuis brigitte bardot à
les amériques
elle est lé plus sexy qu'avant ah oui
franchement parce qu'en battant les
films d'auteur oui voilà et perceval le
gallois est un peu froide un peu on
avait un bloc de glace mais vous savez
quoi vous voulez profond du bernard
henri lévy à les paul emile victor moi
c'est vous dire volume 8 ans et
l'himalaya où c'est l'everest c'est
l'iceberg
il a tout fait ouais c'est toutes les
glaces dans ce que vous êtes devenir
papa je vous dis record je vous dire
comment ariel comment je vais été
acceptée par les français
c'est vrai que maintenant ils vous
aiment vraiment élu au centre et non
mais s'il suffit pas vous les aimiez
maintenant eux et vous êtes rentrée
c'est quand vous avez fait les deux papa
et la maman avec smaïn et antoine de
caunes est là bien dans la vie surtout
l'indien dans la vie l'inde vient de
révéler que vous allez gagner une
popularité normes mais je vous le dis
depuis longtemps nous voit les toits que
j'ai des yeux des pyramides lire oui à
les pyramides le soixante mille entrées
60000 personnes qui se déplacent pour
voir un film et moi j'étais rami
vraiment d'avis qu'on parlait pas du
film de bernard henri lévy attendait
d'anciennes c'est peu dire aux gens si
vous avez l'occasion de voir les prêts
amis de bleu ça fera plaisir à arielle
dombasle
ils le verront tg alors surtout il ya
une flagellation érotique dans un
couvent dans chinois ah ben oui parce
que ariane a compris un truc c'est que
la vraie sensualité s'occupera de vous
laverez sensualité c'est
l'asservissement volontaire à l'homme
qu'on aime
ah oui française après quoi la vraie
sensualité ans invité celle un service
man à l'homme comme m moi j'ai dit ah si
j'étais oublie pas question ah bon on ne
va être servi
vous me donnez pas ce que je sais c'est
dire oui sylvain tapin
moi je dis non ouais après j'ai dit oui
mais au bout d'un moment on va passer on
va passer
chers amis chers ennemis nous allons
passer aux choses sérieuses vous êtes
prête alors valoir quelque chose de bien
magnéto
alors
son mariage avec kent non ça qu on a dit
on a dites vous que vous semblez une
poupée barbie en plus figé ce qui est
pas vrai quand on voit maintenant oui
mais en revanche cdh l on l'a reconnu
oui il n'y eut que j'aimerais je n'ai
jamais eu la poupée mannequin un bon
vous l'a pas offert gaza n'ont pas pas
vraiment c'est le petit garçon à qui on
me fait des barbies je fais tout ce que
j'ai rien vu tout ça et vous mord moi
non mais j'en eus à la maison rey vous
aimiez quoi vous les petites voitures
bombe rouge boum ça se voit voilà donc
j'avais des petites voitures vous
revoilà après six ans d'attenté vous
avez attendu de vous marier pendant six
ans à l'époque on s'est connus vous ne
disiez pas d'ailleurs le nom de votre
fiancée je m'en souviens très bien
et moi je le disais mais pas vous j'ai
toujours été très discret à la télé moi
est alors passé pas si ma confiance ne
sais pas si je les ai vus dans astérix
était sim et vous avez dit la fidélité
et voluptueuse
ah bah évidemment cette cristallisation
comme ça ouais vous n'êtes pas d'accord
verte tous d'accord il est tous d'accord
vous allez gagner notre combat salut
tout le monde est persuadé première
rencontre avec bernard henri lévy donc
du fait dédicacer un livre vous avez 18
ans et lui il écrit donc ça c'est très
vraiment et je dis ça parce que c'est la
saison qui commence à arriver elle
travaille dans quel état il est fait à
ariel en attendant et vous vous dites je
suis foudroyé je suis en transe il
représente il incarne la figure du
prince
c'est très beau leur histoire aussi
intéressé je vous dis ça c'est que c'est
ça vous voulez aussi en lui quand il va
voir ariane bernard henri lévy quand il
va vous voir dans la petite catherine de
heilbronn il est frappé l'île et
chavirait c'est tellement fort qu'il est
un moment il dit je suis épouvante la
vie propose deux femmes y cuisine ans je
garde mon arrivée le baril le baril qui
lave plus blanc que blanc est oui ouais
je viendrai faire ça à la bbc que la
chambre c'est après la poule c
normalement créés ou alors je termine
avec mon histoire
donc un jour vous arrivez à fonder ce
racisme parce que c'est pas n'importe
qui verrait la ville fondée elle
souhaite racisme et marek halter et à la
même heure vous avez rendez vous avec
lui
oui et vous voyons qu'il arrive nous
voyons qu'il arrive pas au rendez vous
secrets il fonce et au lutétia vous
asseyez aux premières
voilà et vous le regardez comme jamais
et vous êtes plus j'avais quitté voilà
c'est fait vous raconter bien
honnêtement je fais mieux l'histoire
d'amour que les proches de josé garcia
dans sa rubrique ans j'espère que manny
je serai stéphane bern et frédéric
mitterrand je m'inquiète ça très bien
non mais sos racisme s'était quand même
quelque chose tu pas se stresser pour
dire que le sida et que saint denis et
que la programmation des films à saint
denis et basse est tous dans le même
mois est-ce que bienveillant que ja et
ds que bernard henri lévy vous a aidé à
résoudre le problème du bac ou bac on
vous a posé comme question j'avoue j'ai
toujours pas compris
vouloir vraiment c'est vouloir ce qu'on
ne veut pas se dédire et loire vraiment
c'est vouloir ce qu'on ne veut pas et
oui mais il faut voilà bambins et toutes
les passes et iberia vous annoncez
heureusement il est capable de répondre
une question alors quand à moi
évidemment au bac j'ai un petit peu
triché j'ai eu de très belles chambres
que vous avez su surfer trouver
quelqu'un qui accepte voulais c'est que
pied donc vers dans les villes étaient
cuites depuis donc nous n d'années alors
je vais rien en commun ce qui est
absolument extraordinaire vous aimez
palais vous adorez les chameaux était ce
les chats vous adorez la musique qui
déteste la musique en politique en 95 et
soutenu balladur oui bah lui ai alors
vous dis oui j'ai dit trois mots pour le
journal le monde
voilà j'ai dit qu'il avait l'esprit
voltairien le soutenir ses troupes et
voir si je peux vous dire et alors je
vous dit de jospin que sa pensée poivre
et sel vous plaît pas vraiment ça doit
faire de la peine à bernard poivre et
sel c'est pas mal pour jospin pensée
poivre et sel on fait comme si on disait
de cohn bendit qu'il a une pensée route
oui et alors
un moment bon vraiment c'est vouloir ce
qu'on veut
non mais ça ne trouverez pas moi ça fait
huit jours que je cherche je ne
comprends pas j'ai je trouve si
quelqu'un comprend il peut nous écrire
donc france l'a jugé lundi pas plus
facile maintenant non
alors le pas par exemple le pape oui que
nous aimons beaucoup tous les deux le
pape oui j'aime beaucoup de paroles
seulement parce que j'ai pas dire qu'on
m'a dit pourquoi ils n'arrivent à côté
de sa photo a rendu la chanson du pape
elle est géniale ouais je sais pas qui
est ce parce qu'il a fait de mieux avec
la danse qui va avec la parkinson si tu
vas en ont fait une énorme en faire
laurent ne vous plaignez pas vous
brûlerez en bas je serai au milieu du
miel y at il un jour là je préfère être
au chaud dans mon gars à bien vous serez
en enfer ça c'est sûr on se dit qu'est
ce que tu vas perdre ton temps tu
pourrais pas si tu veux afin d'en faire
tu pourras parce que explique parce
qu'il y aura pas de cela au paradis la
pac et à mes gâteaux parade mais bonjour
santé donc voila voila c'est un enfer et
damnation ce cas réels pas du tout ce qu
ariel a compris tous les cas c'est
qu'elle a besoin de la parole du pape
pour pouvoir la transgresser vrai fond
pour vous ai compris la fonction
érotique de la religion
catholique va poser enfin j'ai compris
beaucoup de choses avec la religion
catholique vous savez je suis quand même
d'un pays très catholique
le mexique le mexique le ciment social
de la population et pas l'opium du
peuple c'est le catholicisme et moi j'ai
été catholique parce que quand je suis
entré dans les églises mexicaine il y
avait des champs il y avait de la
dévotion
il y avait quelque chose de transcendant
on avait l'impression de rejouer la
première fois que j'ai vu aussi figé
pleurer oui c'est vrai bon en fait c'est
tout de même très excité avant ma vie et
tant mieux parce que maintenant c'est
beaucoup moins drôle un mais deux
d'entre nous on est les deux derniers
voient les arrières c'est vrai que les
psaumes c'est vrai que ce qui a été fait
au nom de l'église est aux mains de
skate plus beau les cantiques les
requiem toute la peinture de soutien
voila voila c'est au nom de dieu alors
les problèmes avec dhl maintenant mais
c'est très court un don qui est du
théâtre
le jugement dernier où c'est là que vous
avez à vous et votre amour d'ailleurs
c'est parce que c'était marqué sur le
fronton donc là plus personne pouvait
faire au fronton de l'atelier j'avais
écrit arielle dombasle dans une pièce de
ballons il a eu un break
voilà après le jour et la nuit le fameux
film dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
que vous avez vu les gens m'appelaient
l'a vu à oui les gens faisaient la queue
pour sortir à paris sur les champs
dites moi que j'aille les tabasser
géorgie
bonds est resté sur roulettes du bac
voilà ce qu'on veut pas alors après donc
maintenant ce qu'il a très bien réussi
c'est sa médiatisation et pourtant vous
étiez content moi je me souviens d'une
fois où on s'est rencontré au
shéhérazade
tous les mois il y avait quelques
caméras bon enfant on avait la même
intimité que ce soir on va regarder non
ça va rester encore un peu on regarde
serge